Are you ready to hit the headlines with us Jay?
Yes, let's do it.
All right, 'cause our first story actually
is about two people that you know.
So would you take this story please?
Okay, a big congratulations
to Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas.
They just welcomed their first baby into the world
with the help of a surrogate.
Oh, come on.
(audience cheer and clap)
They announced on Instagram and asked for privacy
as they celebrate this special time.
I'm so excited for them.
They are such special human beings.
They made us feel family this year
when we celebrated Diwali with them,
and I could not be happier for them.
And I'm so excited for them, it's beautiful.
It's wonderful.
(audience cheer and clap)
He went from a Jonas brother,
now he's a Jonas daddy.
How cute is that?
They have one baby now.
All they need is two more to make a little Jonas baby band.
Oh, I can't wait.
Now, they're all dads.
I know.
It's so exciting.
I feel like everybody roots for them
and this is just no exception, congratulations.
Yeah, congratulations.
Totally, congrats, great story.
Well next, we're looking
at an age old question posed by "Women's day" magazine.
We want your take on this.
Everyone's heard of that term, soulmates.
I wanna find my soulmate.
Well, they're asking, is that real?
Everyone's got their own answer,
but some relationship experts caution the concept
of soulmates could be dangerous.
It could lead to some people focusing too much
on finding the one instead of building
that soulmate connection with somebody special.
Think about that.
So they say basically soulmates takes work.
What do you think?
Well, Drew and Ross,
do you want the truth or do you want?
I want the truth.
Or do you wanna feel good?
She wants the truth, I wanna feel good, go.
I was gonna say the first thing
that came to my mind was the Lizzo song, "Soulmate".
I think it's a great song.
And she says, "I'm my own soulmate."
Yes.
It's a really,
really nice message.
But, the thing is that I think a soulmate is someone
or a mate that helps you find your soul,
and my mates can't even help me find my keys.
So I'm not so sure.
I think my take on this is I believe
that there are people out there,
but there are multiple soulmates
and we're gonna meet them at different times in our life
and they help us find a different part of our soul.
What you just said though,
a mate who helps you find your soul is like, right.
That's humongo, because I do think the idea
that there's one person and you either find them
or you live miserably your whole life is ridiculous
because it infers that relationships aren't any work.
And I think it's because there's so many movies
where the princess finds the prince
and then they live happily ever after, they say,
and it ends.
But what they don't show is that the prince has sleep apnea
and the princess has bad credit.
They don't show you that part.
(audience laugh)
And so we have these expectations
(audience clap)
that are impossible.
Oh my God Ross, we need to produce a romcom together.
Please, the happily ever after, after.
Yes, I couldn't agree more.
I was so excited to hear your take on this
because you did find someone extraordinary whom you met
when you were a monk and weren't available.
And then when it was the right time,
you were open to receiving each other.
Yeah, and it's taken a lot of work
and it's still work every single day,
but I think the point of a soulmate
is who are you willing to put that work in for?
You're always trying to change the other person.
And usually you're trying to change them
to be a bit more like you,
like, "Why are you not organized like me?"
Or, "Why are you not this like me?"
And then you realize, I don't wanna be married to me.
I don't wanna date myself.
I want to be with someone else
who gives me a unique perspective
and brings something fresh.
And I think letting go of that
(audience clap)
has been the best decision.
Can you imagine dating yourself?
I know, can you imagine.
Oh my God, if I dated myself,
I would break up with myself so fast.
I'd be like, "Get outta here."
I don't know what it would be like to date myself.
I have no perspective.
It would be funny though.
Yeah, it would be a good time.
I like to laugh.
All right next, we've seen all
those decorative wooden plaques
with the words live, laugh, love on them.
Well, this one is so awesome, this story
because apparently the phrase has become a huge joke
for gen Z.
"Yahoo life" reports that live, laugh, love
is being now mocked by millions of people,
especially the younger ones on TikTok every day.
Some in sort of this tone, like this video,
Do you see this Kelly?
Look, it says, "Live, laugh, love."
Isn't that precious?
We don't have anything over the couch in the den.
I guess I'm gonna have to get it.
It's just too perfect for our family,
"Live, laugh, love", so simple.
Okay, so that's one part, but they're also using it like,
"I just got ghosted again, live, laugh, love."
Or, "I just filed for bankruptcy, live, laugh, love."
Jay, what's your take on live, laugh, love?
Well, I'm gonna play devil's advocate here.
I think we need a little more live, laugh, love in our life,
but not on a plaque, not in your home.
I think it's interesting.
Like you say, I like the sentiment
to put that out there, live, laugh, love, good.
It's just signs of words on walls.
When you walk into someone's kitchen
and they have a big sign that says, "Eat."
I'm like, "I know."
(Jay and Drew laugh)
Or when you go in the bedroom and it says,
"Sleep or dreams."
Yeah, I get it.
What does it say in your bathroom,
'cause I know what to do there too.
That's brilliant.
But the sentiment is true.
In fact, we just wrote for the magazine,
the new issue we're making, for the heart issue I wrote,
"If there are cracks in your heart,
"let that be space for light to shine through."
Beautiful.
That's beautiful.
Thank you, all right, Jay Shetty likes it, I'm done!
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)